welcome to one of the only reasons I
clean my kitchen a cooking video No hi
my name is first help you know it's
different now in the USA it's big old
boner town' for football season right
now
aka the support we call those
millionaires / spandex and then they hug
each other to the ground over and over
and over it over and over what a concept
and one of the fun things about watching
professional athletes at the height of
their careers at the height of their
athletic aptitude at the height of their
physical ability is eating terrible food
while they're doing it so today I wanted
to make some sort of sports watching
snack that combines two things that my
nose itches I did my own acrylic nails
before this who am i what am I let me
know in the comments down below
game day snack what's one of the most
fun things to eat in groups pizza
because what's more fun and seeing
fellow adults with gross greasy baby
fingers and what's another party staple
pretzels I'm gonna make tiny pizzas but
the crust is gonna be soft pretzel
that's it we got there it's been a
journey I went on Pinterest and I found
a soft pretzel recipe from sprinkle some
sugar calm put the link down below pull
this closure I did this earlier in the
week and it turned out shockingly well
I'm gonna do again but I won't try them
like act like it's the first time I've
done it but I will be genuinely pissed
if it doesn't work out this time let's
do it here are the ingredients you need
for soft pretzels 2 and 1/4 tbsp aka one
packet of active dry yeast nickname for
my vagina that was a reenactment of all
the add supporters of this videos one
cup of warm water it takes a long time
gonna water my kitchen to get warm
please subscribe turn into a corner one
cup of warm water 1 tablespoon of
unsalted butter melted 1 teaspoon of
sugar a teaspoon of sugar I only have
Splenda because what am i what
what am I am I what a beautiful setup a
teaspoon of salt three cups of
all-purpose flour four tablespoons of
baking soda and of course salt for
sprinkling on top and then whatever you
want for your pizza accoutrement free
you having a 475 degrees it is sports
you're also supposed to have like a
stand mixer like a countertop mixer like
for cakes and baking and stuff but I
don't have that but I have these I could
call them Snooki and JWoww
you don't think that they can accomplish
much but then look at their social media
following and you're very impressed by
that but this was not completely cleaned
out from the last usage we're gonna
combine one packet of yeast with our
warm water and our sugar and we're gonna
mix it until it gets frothy that's not
an adjective you want to ever describe
anything about yourself frothy yeast to
break drag names this is a little bit
like wet cardboard bread or like if
you've got a yeast infection and while
you're camping
that looks frothy ah now we put in our
salt eyeballing it and then our melted
butter then we're gonna add one cup of
flour at a time mix it as we go until it
turns into a batter that's not very
sticky frothy in sticky out alright
that's about a cup and we mix two cup oh
it's becoming very thick thic see and
see your internet you have a mixer this
would be way better it's like playing
football without a quarterback and then
you put the kicker in you're like just
do what you do with your legs with your
arm
Laska and it says you might need less or
more depending on how your dough is
though is like a teenager with tumblr
you just don't know what the combination
is gonna lead to oh boy good thing that
I put on acrylic nails before this I'm
so 2000 and late this is once you've
added about 3 cups of flour and the
dough is no longer sticky you should
need it for 5 minutes which is a lot
like just humans you just want to be
kneaded like 5 minutes so we're all just
piles the dough that why don't you need
knead the dough like you're a
quarterback supporting a tight end that
caught a ball after a play
slap it in the dough is part of
themselves you better realize a football
player slap each other's butt so much
hey go play don't really get it next
time your shoulder will go back into its
socket
once you're done eating your dough you
should shape it into a ball and let it
rest back in the bowl for about 15
minutes
go on suck my dick Tom Brady meanwhile
it says prepare the baking soda bath
we're gonna boil 2 cups of water with 4
tablespoons of baking soda in it 2 cups
of water boil once your baking soda bath
comes to a boil and all the baking soda
that seems to be dissolved you put it in
some sort of tray or pan and you let it
become lukewarm it's like when you're
watching a football game go faster
you're more interesting why do your
spandex pants only go to below your knee
why don't they go to your ankle oh good
so now if you were gonna make regular
soft pretzels you would cut your dough
into strips and you would twist them and
form them into pretzel shapes but
because I want to make them into pizza
crusts I'm going to cut my dough and
flatten it into tiny pizza crusts
looking shapes I'll take like this and
we just flatten it out like a tiny like
personal pizza crust you're gonna take
your formed pizza pretzel dough and put
it in the baking soda bath for about 2
minutes let's make more crust crust a
frothy needi all the adjectives in this
recipe I think might be coming back 2018
vision board it's a 2 minutes is up I
have this baking sheet it's now nonstick
and I'm gonna put these guys on the bake
machine this recipe says to bake these
pretzels for about eight to nine minutes
but because I want to make them pizza
I'm gonna bake them for like 2 or 3
minutes and then add the pizza toppings
to them and then bake them for the rest
of the time and see what happens the one
thing we have to do before they go in
the oven it take some coarse salt and
sprinkle it over top okay now let's put
them in the oven for a few minutes all
right it was a football ok our pretzels
have been in the oven for about 2 or 3
minutes now we're gonna top them with
some pizza stuff so pizza sauce goes in
the middle I have this six cheese
Italian shredded cheese good job good
job I also have vegan pepperoni
this is vegan but I have vegan pepperoni
bacon pepperoni
felis like a moist teen okay we'll leave
a couple plain okay back into the oven
it goes for like five or six more
minutes it also says that when the
pretzels come out of the oven get some
more melted butter and brush them with
it immediately make it shiny oh these
look really good can we run let these
cool down for a second and move them to
a plate this is a touchdown Oh
so I'm sitting up here now because I was
getting my thumbnail up here but then I
bit into it and I just want you to you
my authentic reaction that [ __ ] this is
really delicious oh these are so goddamn
delicious I highly encourage you to make
these for yourself if you do make any of
these pretzel pretzel what am i calling
these frets frets up breakfast shy call
these pretzels like pizzas but pretzels
if you make your own pretzel let me know
tag me on instagram or twitter or
wherever the [ __ ] you post your social
media and if you like this video give it
a thumbs up and please do not forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel click
the link in the description below and
hit that Bell notification so you know
when I upload my videos cuz as for the
moment it's Tuesdays and Thursdays but
we'll see what happens
enjoy your princess other than that I
don't know Oh No Oh got it all over my
acrylic nail set Oh
[Music]